so the standard museum specimen for a
mammal is a stuffed study skin where the
skin has been stripped off the body it's
been filled with cotton
there have been wires put in the feet
and the tails and then it's sewn back up
and pinned out on a board and dried
there's a label attached to the specimen
which gives the locality and information
about sex and reproductive data standard
external measurements that are taking a
field who collected it in the date of
collection where it came from and so
forth and then this is permanently
archived in a research collection like
this or the Smithsonian or something and
in addition to the skin the skull is is
removed it's cleaned by carnivorous
beetles
the method of of using beetles these
carnivorous Beatles called dermestid
beetles to clean skeletal material clean
the flesh off of bones is used by
museums and so forth around the world
but some method that was developed here
a specimen would come in from the field
if it's prepared in the field as the
skeletal material we will be dried in
the field if it's prepared here it'll be
dried here sometimes it'll if it's large
enough it'll be soaked in water before
it's dried to get as much of the blood
out of the bone as possible then that
specimen will be put in with the bugs
the bugs will eat it eat the meat off it
if the bugs are really hungry it can
take as little as 24 hours to do that
for a small specimen they come out from
the bugs they get soaked and the
residual little pieces of meat or
gristle cartilage that the bugs don't
take off will be picked off by hand and
then they typically depending upon the
size of the animal it gets soaked in an
ammonia bath or or some kind of a fat
solvent bath to get as much of the fat
out of the bones as possible
so here's skeletonized ground squirrel
if you're going to kill something yeah
you want to maximize the potential use
of it not just for today but forever
these looked like Becky Lee it's the
bony penis from from the male's of
certain species of mammals there are
five groups of mammals that have a bone
in the penis